hello and welcome to my latest monthly
leaders briefing you're joining me here
from eckington leisure centre in the
swimming pool which i'm sure many of you
aware is currently closed but for a very
very good reason we're currently
undergoing some major works to refurbish
and realign the pool and as well as
introduce a number of carbon climate
change initiatives like solar panels on
the roof and air source heat pumps which
we hope will make the pool warmer and
make the whole facility much more carbon
friendly and actually probably one of
the most carbon friendly in the whole
area this is really exciting time for
the council and it's projects like this
that we're doing around the district
that are helping us to
meet our climate change commitments
moving on to another piece of sad news
we've recently learned of the death of
one of our former councillors peter
ramshaw who served the ashov award
for many years with with great service
to
his residents and that community and our
thoughts and prayers and condolences are
very much with his family at this this
difficult time and we want to say a big
thank you
for all of peter's work over the years
and then another really sad event that
has gripped the nation is the incredibly
sad death of sir david amos mp uh in in
hugely tragic circumstances
again our thoughts and prayers are with
his family and all of his colleagues at
this extremely difficult time
you know the murder of a public servant
doing his job and representing his
people is an incredibly awful thing to
have happened and it must make us ask
questions about all of our
collective safety but it's vital that we
as public servants and politicians and
and council officers continue to be open
uh facing to the public and engage with
the public
and so we don't want to to change too
much or put up any barriers or walls
from residents accessing our services or
accessing their local councils so we
want to continue to do those engagement
events but we will have to be mindful of
public safety moving forward
one of those recent events was our meet
the council where we we we held two
events one in eckington here and one
down in
clay cross and these events were all
about showing our residents about the
services that we provide as a district
council and giving residents the
opportunity to ask me and some of my
cabinet colleagues fellow councillors
questions about what the council's doing
to address the issues that they care
about and that's a really important
manifesto commitment for us we we pledge
to be a listening council so doing those
events is a great way to be able to talk
to our residents and find out about the
issues that they've been facing and give
them the opportunity to to raise issues
with us as their
local councillors we've also recently
done a national customer service week
event at our offices at mill lane where
we invited residents to come in and talk
to us about some of the services we
provide right from our council base and
then recently we also did
our armed forces event celebration in
drumfield where
we had a number of members of the
different armed forces community come
and and and talk to residents about some
of the uh the things that they do
we had some fantastic vehicles on site
in the car park next to the leisure
center and we had an excellent uh trade
and
market uh stall event in the in the
leisure centre itself as well as a
church service to commemorate the work
that our
fantastic armed forces community do for
us
so moving on we've also recently
introduced a new policy
for for licensing for taxi drivers and
private hire vehicles we've introduced
mandatory cctv which is in line with the
the new government guidance around
licensing and we're really proud to be
one of the first councils in davashi to
have done this we feel it will help make
our residents and the drivers themselves
feel more safe and more comfortable
when when using those services we're
also going to be working with
neighbouring district councils and
authorities up in south yorkshire to
encourage them to also
adopt the policy
and and that will make it much better
for the whole region to have that policy
in place
we also wanted to remind everyone that
earlier this year we launched a british
sign language video interpreter service
at our council offices and our leisure
centres and that's to help make the uh
the council services more accessible to
the deaf community so we want to remind
everyone and hope that those members of
the deaf community will be able to use
that when they come and visit us at our
leisure centres or council offices
in other news we've also
relaunched our community action grants
for the next round of our action grant
scheme so that's for grants for
community groups for up to 500 pounds
and that's to help
different groups around the district to
be able to tackle some of the local
issues or or support local events within
their area so please do get in touch and
apply for one of the grants if you feel
it might be useful in your community
we've also launched again our eco
schools grant scheme
this is for grants for up to 500 pounds
for secondary schools and up to 250
pounds for primary schools and it's to
support our students to be able to carry
out projects that are supporting the the
climate change mission that we all have
it's really exciting project and we'd
encourage all of our schools to apply
now we've also been working across the
county with other district councils and
the county council to set up what's
known as vision derbyshire now this is a
project that's all about ensuring that
the different tiers of councils
collaborate much better on projects that
affect the whole county and one of the
schemes that vision derbish has recently
set up is a business support scheme now
this is a this is to offer any
businesses around the county as free
support and advice but we're also
offering as part of that scheme grants
of up to
ten thousand pounds to eligible
businesses so if you're a business owner
yourself uh please do look it up and
find out more information about it and
if you're eligible please do apply for
the grants because they're there to
support you particularly as we as we
recover from covered so finally thank
you everyone for for watching today
please do keep stay tuned to our website
and our social media accounts for all
the latest news i hope you found the
updates today useful
and hopefully you'll look forward to
joining us here
back at eckington pool
hopefully around christmas time when we
reopen
to the public and it will look
absolutely fantastic i can assure you so
look forward to seeing you then and
thank you very much
you